c'est que ça fasse monter les
hospitalisations
les cas peuvent se transformer en
expliquer la gestion en général y ait un
délai de deux semaines entre la montée
des cas elle a monté des
hospitalisations et le point tournant ce
qui explique tout ce que vous allez
entendre ce soir de la bouche du premier
ministre c'est un rapport de l'institut
national d'excellence en santé et en
services sociaux qu'on appelle l'inesss
qui a fait une première présentation au
premier ministre et au gouvernement
lundi qui des principales mais hier ils
ont fait de nouvelles projections en
incluant le variant un micron dans leurs
projections et on s'aperçoit que début
janvier la capacité hospitalière le
nombre de lits au québec la capacité
pourrait être atteinte et donc mettre en
danger m menacer la stabilité
du réseau de la santé et c'est la raison
pour laquelle le premier ministre
s'adressait à dos et s'apprête à
annoncer un train de mesures de
resserrement de mesures solides la
projection des hospitalisations dont
vous parlez puis monsieur legault s'est
fait résumé tout ça avec son conseil de
crise entre guillemets c'est que ça va
dans le pire des scénarios
mi-janvier à 1225 une nouvelle
hospitalisation pendant qu'on voit que
le premier ministre installe on va
l'écouter et on va après prendre le
temps avec des médecins des analyses
d'analyser tout ça a tout de suite
bonsoir de monde écoutez je vais vous le
dire tout de suite je n'ai pas des
bonnes nouvelles à vous annoncer
malheureusement au cours des derniers
jours on a vu une explosion du nombre de
cores aujourd'hui chez préliminaire on
est rendu à plus de 3700 corps et les
experts pensent que le nombre de corps
vont continuer à augmenter et le nombre
d'hospitalisations aussi vont continuer
à augmenter en trop à cause de la
présence du nouveau variant au micron
qui selon les experts est plus
contagieux donc ça veut dire les gens
ont plus de chances de l'attraper c'est
plus facile de l'attraper quand on est
en contact avec une autre personne est
donc
les experts pensent que dans les
prévisions les hospitalisations vont
augmenter d'un prochaines semaines
évidemment les hospitalisations c'est la
clé c'est depuis longtemps de notre
grande source d'inquiétude parce qu'on a
un réseau de la santé qui est déjà
fragile on a des travailleurs de la
santé qui depuis 21 mois soignent les
patients qu'aux vide et soigne aussi les
paliers les patients qu'on pourrait
appeler les patients réguliers
donc ça s'accumule depuis presque deux
ans et donc quand on entend que les
hospitalisations vont augmenter de façon
importante dans les prochains jours les
prochaines semaines ben il faut agir bon
évidemment je comprends que tous les
québécois
sont annie et tout le monde moi le
premier on est tanné mais
malheureusement
j'ai besoin de vous aurez besoin on a
encore une bataille à mener j'ai besoin
de vous au retrait
l'effort de chacun vont être très
importants ça va prendre du courage la
détermination
après 21 mois c'est dur mais on va être
frappée c'est certain que le fait qu'on
soit mieux vacciner carrière d'un homme
ça va nous aider mais malgré ça on va
être frappé et ça c'est important il
faut tout le monde comprenne les experts
puis pas juste des experts l'ont on a
des chiffres à chaque jour pour le
prouver
les personnes non vaccinées ont quinze
fois plus de chances d'attraper le virus
que les personnes qui sont vaccinées 15
fois plus de chances donc ça c'est
prouvé ce scientifique
et on peut le constater sur le terrain
par contre même si des gens vaccinés ont
moins de chances d'attraper point de
chance se retrouve à l'hôpital il ya
quand même des risques et évidemment
quand on voit le nombre de coques est
rendu à 3700 nouveau corps par jour
aujourd'hui
c'est assez facile de comprendre qui a
un impact qui aura un impact sur les
hospitalisations
l'autre chose aussi que les experts
peuvent maintenant confirmer c'est que
la troisième dose aide à réduire les
risques d'attraper le virus puis d'avoir
des conséquences qui amène les gens à
aller à l'hôpital donc ça devient comme
une plaie importante cette troisième
dose et park ont tantôt christian vous
vous en parler un peu plus mais c'est
important de respecter l'ordre selon les
risques de chacun évidemment tout le
monde va comprendre sont le bien vu
depuis le début les personnes qui sont
plus âgés ont plus de risque d'avoir des
conséquences graves dont cet important
de les vacciner en premier donc à tous
demain on vaccine toutes les personnes
de 60 ans et plus pour avoir la
troisième dose pour mener nulle et
protégé est important d'aller chercher
cette 3e d'eau est important dit aussi
que déjà les gens qui sont dans les chu
celle des dans les résidences pour aînés
ont déjà reçu la troisième dose est donc
le ministre de la santé puis son équipe
travaille très fort pour
accélérer cette vaccination cette
troisième dose qui j'entends des
personnes qui nous disent bon mais
pourquoi vous l'ouvrez pas à toutes les
personnes de 18 ans et plus
si on ouvrait demain matin aux personnes
de 18 ans et plus ça voudrait dire qu'on
pourrait se retrouver dans une situation
où une personne de 40 ans pourrait
passer devant une personne de 110 ans
qui est beaucoup plus vulnérable
beaucoup plus à risque donc comme on le
fait avec la première dose l'année
passée on veut y aller par ordre de
risques et donc il y aller graduellement
partir de janvier pour aller vers les
moins de 60 ans bon évidemment l'autre
groupe qui est important de vacciner
rapidement
c'est le personnel la santé on a
actuellement un réseau de la santé qui
est fragile donc à donner à chose qu'on
veut c'est de prendre trop de risques
avec le personnel de la santé donc c'est
important encore là de donner la
troisième dose à tout le personnel de la
santé on est entré le christ est en
train de transférer des personnes c'est
vrai que dans certains qu'on peut avoir
la de déshabiller un pour habiller
l'autre mais là encore lost une question
de priorité donc ça se peut qu'on amène
du personnel à venez fait de la
vaccination du personnel qui faisaient
autre chose dans le réseau mais la
priorité des priorités actuellement
c'est vraiment la vaccination puis on ne
reçut qui se faisait 1500 of de venez
nous aider vieillot je contribue en
train de trier ceux qui ont les
compétences pour vacciner lancée mais
500 lots mais j'invite tous les
québécois tous les québécoises tout et
québécoises qui ont la compétence
devenait vacciner de s'inscrire vous
allez sur le site
quebec.com dans la section je contribue
vous donnez votre nom c'est très
important maintenant ce qui est
important de dire c'est que dans cette
bataille et quand même
c'est pas suffisant la vaccination
la deuxième arme qu'on a c'est tout
simple que deux des faux est capable de
réduire les contacts d'être moins
souvent proches de d'autres personnes
puis on se fixe comme objectif de
réduire les contacts de 50% au cours des
prochaines semaines donc j'annonce
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de mesures
qui vont être en place à partir de lundi
donc d'abord tous les commerces dans
tous les commerces on va réduire la
capacité à 50% dans les bars restaurants
salles de spectacles amphithéâtre on va
aussi réduire la capacité à 50% dans les
églises et les lieux de culte on va
aussi réduire la capacité à 50% le 50 %
pourra pas être plus que 250 personnes
puis on va mettre en place aussi dans
les églises et 18 culte le passeport
vaccinale comme par exemple dans l'est
restera maintenant il ya des activités
qui sont très à risque qui amènent des
éclosions on pense aux portes et de
bureaux karaoké la danse donc à partir
de lundi ce sera aussi interdite pour ce
qui des écoles depuis le début de la
pandémie
on a dit la dernière place qu'on veut
fermer ce sont les écoles parce que
c'est important pour nos enfants donc on
veut pas fermer des écoles puis en plus
ça aide la vaccination des enfants donc
deux bonnes raisons pour ne pas fermer
des écoles donc même chose au retour des
fêtes au primaire les écoles vont
rouvrir et à la date prévue par contre
les écoles secondaires ceux qui avaient
des dates d'école de prévu dans la
semaine du 3 janvier ça va être des
cours à distance mais à partir du 10
janvier ça va être en présentiel dans
les écoles secondaires pour ce qui est
des cégeps et les unes et les
universités là aussi ça va être 10
janvier où une date ultérieure d'un cas
où la date prévue était derrière
concernant les laisse par les activités
extérieures
ont laissé ouvert par contre il ya eu
des problèmes et tournoi aps les
compétitions vont maintenant passer
toujours de lundi être interdit la
grosse question que les gens se
demandent qu'est ce qu'on fait que des
rassemblements dans les maisons dans les
résidences inclus impôts le temps des
fêtes
malheureusement on doit mettre un
maximum à 10 personnes donc 10 personnes
maximum dans les maisons dans les
résidences même pour le temps des fêtes
et même à dix personnes faut être très
prudent puis le faire juste c'est
absolument nécessaire
il ya des risques dans les maisons bon
d'abord important de 10 l'aération c'est
important ouvrir régulièrement une
fenêtre dans la maison pour faire
circuler l'air et est très très très
prudent avec les personnes vulnérables
les personnes vulnérables
il faut garder ses distances et puis
idea demain éviter de prendre des
risques c'est une question de jugement
il ya un risque et donc il faut agir en
conséquence et rudent parce que je le
répète le var hier au micro et très très
facile attrapé donc prenons pas de
risques donc notre plan deux grands
éléments
deux choses sur lesquelles faut se
concentrer d'abord quand c'est rendu
votre tour aller chercher la troisième
dose
deuxièmement ben réduirez vos contacts
que ce soit dans votre travail que ce
soit dans vos activités quand vous allez
faire des courses où que ce soit dans
votre propre maison quand vous avez
d'autres personnes dans votre maison
faut réduire les contacts et pour gagner
cette bataille j'ai besoin de vous
autres l'autre chose qui est importante
c'est quand vous avez des symptômes sont
eux-mêmes grippe prenez pas de chance
allez vous faire tester puis rester à la
maison le yo à partir de lundi ils vont
voir des tests rapides que vous pouvez
faire vous même qui vont être
disponibles dans les pharmacies dont
vous allez pouvoir aller chercher cinq
thèses par personne donc si vous avez
des symptômes si c'est positif ballif
chercher un vrai test pcr qui restez
chez vous en quarantaine c'est paul
temps quand vous avez des symptômes ou
quand vous avez été testé positif de
voir du monde c'est une question de
respect pour les autres donc en
terminant
je sais que les québécois sont tannés
mais tout le monde a un rôle à jouer si
on veut gagner la bataille si on veut
passer au travers je sais que des
personnes qui vont des vont vous avez
changé d'idée t depuis 21 mois ça monte
ça descend ça monte ça descend faut
suivre ça
chaque jour et faut agir en conséquence
faut pas avoir peur on n'est pas là la
part au recueil de dix mois je veux
m'assurer que ce que j'ai dit il ya une
semaine ou deux soit encore vrai
aujourd'hui
l'important c'est de regarder fois
demain les donner quand ça va bien le
dire que ça vaut mieux puis de donner un
peu d'espoir puis quand ça va mal bello
dit que l'heure pour un bout de temps
faut faire des efforts donc depuis le
début depuis 21 mois le québec était un
des endroits où les consignes ont été
les plus sévères au continuer de le
faire on va continuer s'assurer qu'on
réagit rapidement et on va laisser le
recueil de côté s'il ya une chose qu'on
a appris avec cette crise c'est qu'il
faut être très humble parce que ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui c'est peut-être parce
qu'on va voir demain ou la semaine
prochaine donc je pense est important de
réagir rapidement pu s'ajuster au fur et
à mesure donc ce soir je pense aux
québécois ou québécois qui sont tannés
je pense aux québécois qu'ils ont hâte
de voir leur famille élargie
je pense aux commerçants qui ont eu deux
années 2 qui
se disent je voyais la lumière au bout
du tunnel puis loeb il faut toujours
trouver 50 % d'incapacité je comprends
le que c'est pas facile mais je demande
à tout le monde d'avoir du courage de
prendre soin de vous et de prendre soin
de vos proches surtout des personnes
vulnérables donc je compte sur vous
merci et sur ce je passe de parole à
christian chivu parler de la vaccination
or m merci beaucoup françois et bonsoir
tout le monde alors peut-être à quelques
points premièrement j'aimerais rappeler
que les gens de 70 ans et plus peuvent
prendre troisième dose à dose de rappel
depuis déjà le 22 novembre alors jusqu'à
il ya quelques jours on était en dessous
de notre capacité c'est-à-dire qu'on ne
vacciner pas au maximum de ce qu'on
pouvait faire l'ange réitère aux gens de
60 et disant d'aller chercher très
rapidement lordose
comme le dit premier ministre notre
priorité sur les travailleurs de la
santé à qui je réitère en à peu près 20%
nos travailleurs de la santé qui sont
éligibles depuis quand même quelques
temps donc d'aller chercher leur
troisième dose maintenant sur
l'intervalle la bonne nouvelle c'est que
premièrement pour tenir compte de la
situation
épidémiologique que l'on a actuellement
mais aussi en raison de l'arrivée du var
ya la santé publique nos experts sont
d'avis qu'ils préférable maintenant de
réduire l'intervalle à un minimum de
trois ans alors ça c'est un très très
gros chargement on passe de 6 mois 3
mois puis rappelez vous encore il ya
quelques jours une des raisons pour
lesquelles envac ce n'est pas aussi
rapidement ce parce qu'on était limitée
par le ciment alors avec l'arrivée du
varien la santé publique ont décidé
qu'ils étaient à propos de réduire
l'intervalle alors ils ont pesé les
coûts de pour et le contre sommet je
pense que tu es assez évident avec ce
qu'on a vu dans les statistiques des
derniers jours d'accélérer et de réduire
l'intervalle c'est la première joue fort
de sow mais c'est sûr qu'on a juste
notre calendrier alors avec cette
recommandation lors des rendez-vous
additionnels vont être disponibles tout
à l'heure le premier ministre a expliqué
qu on a mille cinq cents personnes qui
ont levé la main c'est ce que nos
équipes le à ce moment sont en train de
réajuster tous nos horaires de
vaccination nous si tu donnes jeux sont
un exemple hier on a vacciné 53 mille
personnes avec des jaunes commençait à
ce juste et lorsqu'on a vu le depuis
lundi qu'il y avait un besoin
d'augmenter le taux alors donc nos
équipes sont là dessus ça veut dire que
dès lundi prochain dès lundi le 20
décembre le début des gens de 65 ans et
plus vont pouvoir prendre le rendez vous
se sait lundi de 20 décembre
et à compter de lundi une 27 soit une
semaine plus tard ce sera les 60 ans et
plus mais en parallèle je le répète on
va prioriser nos travailleurs de la
santé nos plus vulnérables ceux qui sont
asthmatiques et cetera alors si vous
êtes par exemple un asthmatique de 60
ans vous pouvez aller vous faire
vacciner et je le répète ça veut dire
que tous nos groupes d'âge après le 60
heures vont pouvoir est ouvert à compter
de janvier mais étant donné qu'on a une
super bonne réaction de la part des
vaccinateurs qui viennent nous aider je
rappelle aux plus jeunes que si on est
capable d'accélérer encore plus la
vaccination on va le faire puis vous
savez de josé dit dans une semaine on
fait des 65 ans dans l'aude semaine
c'est à dire entre noël et jour de l'an
on devrait avoir fait des 60 ans et plus
mais si on est capable d'accélérer puis
la réaction qu'on a eu des québécois dé
jacques sont venus nous aider à je
contribue pourrait nous permettre à
l'air encore plus rapidement je pense
que c'est important de le dire à tout le
monde
maintenant
si ya peut-être d'autres personnes qui
vont venir nous aider le jouet pas les
dents nous dans le détail on avait
d'ailleurs encore une heure une belle
discussion avec nos médecins
spécialistes qui nous ont à faire là ils
sont en réunion demain pour capable de
venir nous donner un coup de main ça ça
va nous donner encore si c'est pas dans
les 15 cents personnes que j'ai compté
tout à l'heure c'est vraiment corvée de
vaccination compte un train de remettre
plus rassurer les québécois on a déjà
montré que la machine pouvait livrer 100
mille vaccins par jour j'allais voir
qu'on va être capable de le faire
surtout avec l'aide qu'on aura ce moment
loki qui s'en viennent nous donner un
coup de main pied en plus bas il est
question de la vaccination de l'influx
has l'influent zone ou pharmacien ci
était consacrée jusqu'à maintenant c'est
presque terminé alors hier je regardais
dans nos statistiques il y avait déjà
trois mille bac 5 avait été fait par des
pharmaciens donc dépendamment des
régions saucisses une bonne nouvelle
quand je regarde l'addition de jeu
contribue je regarde l'aide scandé des
pharmaciens des médecins spécialistes et
des gens quand on est rendu cinquante
mille rappelez-vous le chiffre que
monsieur paré audi pop tarts à la banque
worms et mardi qu'on s'est vus là dessus
mais je pense que d'atteindre le 800
milles par semaine c'est très possible
même à très court temps quand on l'a
déjà prouvé maintenant ni région aussi
bon nous à bizet voudrais que les gens
soient pas surpris parce que on se voit
on sera peut-être moins souvent dans les
prochains jours j'espère vous l'espérez
aussi mais je veux rassurer les gens
peut-être que des régions qui vont aller
plus vite que d'autres parce qu'on n'a
pas les mêmes situations de vaccination
puis des fois ci il fallait ouvrir nous
une catégorie 60 ans plus vite une
semaine parce que on peut le faire ne
vous inquiétez pas nous on va aller à la
rapidité compass les catégories d'âge
comme le premier ministre il le dire en
termes de priorités de risque pour la
vaccination dernier point je veux aussi
rassurer les gens qui sont dans les rpa
et dans les chcd c'est important parce
que on a vu la première vague une
deuxième vague on s'est amélioré on
s'est amélioré mais nos dose de rappel
99% sont terminés dans nowhere peron
gazon chcd on met beaucoup d'emphase en
ce moment parce que je le rappelle c'est
un virus qui est très contagieux
rappelez-vous mardi on a indiqué qu'il
fallait absolument avoir le port du
masque par exemple dans les aires
communes juste aller voir ma mère cette
semaine c'est pas une bonne nouvelle
d'avoir ça mais en même temps je le dis
il faut porter le masque il faut faire
attention la distanciation
particulièrement dans les aires communes
faites attention parce que même si vous
avez votre troisième dose même si vous
avez votre troisième dose il faut faire
attention le virus circule et c'est
important de faire et on demande comme
on le fait mais on voit encore plus
exigeants on va demander le passeport
vaccinale pour tous les visiteurs et des
projets de jeu c'est que des fois c'est
difficile on le fait déjà mais
j'aimerais que les visiteurs ne soit pas
choqué de cette mesure là que des
projets d'un comprennent bien mais c'est
important de respecter ces mesures là et
la bonne nouvelle avec des tests rapides
on va aussi rendre nos tests rapides
disponibles dans les rpa et dans les chu
s'était alors en terminant faut
continuer et puis l'équipe de daniel
paris fait un excellent travail et on
vous tiendrons informés dans les
prochains jours pour les catégories de
vaccination qui sont en mode 60 on
va être frappée à dire monsieur legault
et pour résister à l'assaut ben il va
falloir faire deux choses accélérer la
troisième dose ouvriers de l'entente et
réduire et c'est là que ça va faire mal
réduire les contacts de 50 pour ça ce
qui veut dire
party de bureau au revoir car ok on n'a
pas le même pas réduire de 50% les
restaurants les salles de spectacles
sébastien monsieur legault le dirait
d'écouté non seulement je me dédie mais
on va mettre leur gueule de côté devant
la marie de cas on n'a pas le choix dit
il et on est déjà à 3700 pour les
dernières 24 heures la journée même pas
encore fini certaines sources évoquent
même le chiffre de 4000 comme bilan
qu'ont publiera demain en fin de matinée
devant cette tournure des événements on
craint que le nombre d'hospitalisations
augmente et des projections de
l'institut national d'excellence en
santé et services sociaux dit que si
rien n'est fait on va atteindre la
capacité d'hospitalisation au québec
c'est ce qui explique essentiellement
pourquoi monsieur legault fait c'est
avant 60 ans résume rapidement et michel
et on veut c'est fanny je vous entends
parler on va bien sûr retourner à la
période de questions mais sébastien d'un
mollah rassemblement privé là dix
personnes se termine et puis il le dit
on veut rester les plus sévères au
canada voilà alors vous pouvez vous
rassembler à noël à 10 personnes peu
importe le nombre de jours où le feu
vous le faites il avait évoqué la
possibilité de limiter le nombre de
jours mais ce sera non de jeu illimité
le masque en classe pour tous ce sera le
retour du masque en classe pour les
élèves les restaurants les bars les
salles de spectacle essentiellement tous
les lieux publics là où il peut y avoir
des rassemblements de personnes ça passe
à 50 % des soutes toutes ces mesures là
on passa entre en vigueur à partir du 20
décembre le 20 décembre c'est lundi
prochain les commerces également les
commerces et les gens qui vont aller
faire leurs courses pour noël 50% de
moins de clients dans les commerces on
veut éviter les contacts on veut limiter
les contacts et c'est la façon qu'on a
trouvée pour le faire en limitant la
capacité des commerces et des lieux où
les gens se rassemblent très bien
troisième dose monsieur dubé un michel
david et stéphanie on l'a vue insiste
là-dessus subi il ya encore vingt
vaccination qui s'en viennent
c'est une nouvelle course contre le
virus à un peu comme on avait vu la date
de l'année dernière
bon la vaccination la corvette tout ça
c'est très bien mais les 1500 personnes
qui ont fui se sont portés volontaires
on sait pas combien là dedans levon vont
réellement faire le travail je vous
arrête désole michel
période de questions pour vient tout de
suite
pour arriver jusque là aujourd'hui ils
vous avez choisi de parler à 18 heures
j'imagine pour rejoindre un maximum de
personnes comment on vend cette salade
de retour en arrière est de retour entre
guillemets l'effort de guerre
écoutez je pense que il faut dire la
vérité aux québécois
depuis quelques jours on a vu
le nombre de corps presque doublé on
veut être capable de continuer de
soigner nos gens dans nos hôpitaux
etc la balance des inconvénients
donc actuellement il faut prendre ça au
sérieux la situation est critique
c'est pas seulement au québec la même
chose dans notre allié aux états unis en
europe donc on n'est pas différent des
autres
probablement qu'on voit un peu mieux
s'en sortir parce qu'on est plus
vacciner mais faut faire des efforts pis
y'a pas de meilleur
la première chose de ce fait vacciner la
deuxième chose la plus importante c'est
de réduire les contacts donc ce pôle
temps des taupes humaine 10 dans les
maisons faut être prudent avec les
personnes vulnérables parce qu'il ya un
risque réel pour les personnes et pau
notre réseau de la santé en suivi dans
votre longue liste de mesures annoncées
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup pour les
commerçants les restaurateurs les bas
est en acier qui ont trimé dur eux aussi
qui ont perdu beaucoup d'argent est ce
que l'aide financière sera aussi au
rendez-vous pour absolument les mêmes
programmes qu'on a utilisé quand on a
fermé commerces vont être disponibles on
a parlé aussi avec le gouvernement
fédéral pour s'assurer que pour les
individus aussi l'aide soit disponible
pour les personnes qui sont touchées
donc mais pour répondre à votre question
concernant les commerces les entreprises
ceux qui sont touchés vont avoir droit
au programme des finances
henri ou à la devise in à la presse oui
bonjour ou trois
ans trouve parler des salles des ders
peu inquiète pas vous craignez que seuls
nous on va rien me transporte des
ravages dans les sages s'est levé et
commun l'expérience de melgven pu nous
aider à limiter ça quel genre de mesure
on peut mettre de plus pour unix arrive
il y en a plusieurs la plus grande c'est
la vaccination
rappelez vous je pense que nous on est
excessivement heureux que
quelques pourcentages prennent aux gens
sont tous vaccinés troisième dose donc
c'est des gens qui étaient les plus
vénérables cité minutes à plus faible
que les autres pour soi qu'on a commencé
par eux que ça c'est des genres c'est
déjà derrière nous je répète que un gros
enjeu pour la bévue c'était toute la
question de prévention et contrôle des
infections alors on voit encore et
insisté pour que ces mesures le soin
place parce que tous je le répète même
quand on est vacciné troisième dose il
faut continuer de faire attention alors
tous les jours moi je veux le faire
encore dans les prochains jours avec nos
pdj pilier responsables qu'on nomme
localement c'est de s'assurer que les
mesures de protection et de contrôle des
infections sont suivies
je pense que jusqu'à maintenant on était
capable d'éviter des infections ou des
éclosions majeur ne très très très peu
de corps et c'est pour ça que j'ai mal
gré je veux terminer là dessus malgré
l'inconfort qu'on demande par exemple
des masques d'aller dans les rues dans
les zones communes je pense que c'est le
minimum qu'on peut demander pour
s'assurer de nos gens soient bien
protégés
ensuite monsieur legault sur les
rassemblements de dix personnes qui
travaillent un 20-6 tard faire la pige
je sais que comme vous deviez vous
regardez les données froidement chaque
jour le seastar fasse quelque chose que
vous feriez différemment parce qu'on
voyait quand même cette hausse levené
depuis quelques semaines donc est ce qu
est ce que vous seriez plus prudes
incite enfin
vous êtes envoyé cette hausse le venir
depuis quelques semaines je pense pas
que quelques semaines quelqu'un aurait
dit il va avoir trois mille sept cent
cinquante par jour au québec que faut
être réaliste et qu'il faut poète
orgueilleux faut être humble il faut
regarder ce au jour le jour parce que
quand vous regardez depuis le monde mars
2020 ça monte ça descend ça monte ça
descend quand ce à dessein s'étant donné
de l'espoir puis encouragé qui
permettent aux gens de se voir quand sam
on est là il faut prendre des mesures
donc il faut s'ajuster presqu'à chaque
jour donc je pense que
les décisions qu'on prend doivent être
continuellement ajusté et puis bon
compte sur on continue de faire sa
gym question bonjour lors la voie gens
ne m'ont rien actuellement c'est le se
trouvaient des rendez vous pour se faire
dépister ça prend plusieurs jours avant
d'avoir un résultat qu'est ce qui peut
être fait pour venir la situation
actuellement mais il ya eu 2 un jeu sur
le dépistage prends mon match très
content que les gens ils se faire
dépister ces seconde main la première
chose c'est que je l'expliqué mardi au
dernier point de presse c'est qu'il faut
pas aller se faire dépister
juste pour avant d'aller impact et on se
comprend et c'est là peut-être que des
gens qui ne devraient peut-être pas dans
les lignes de dépistage si on pas de
symptômes oui on pas été en contact avec
quelqu'un alors dans des geôles il faut
répéter aux gens qu'on va se faire si tu
es si on est en contact avec quelqu'un
ou si on a des symptômes la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'avec leur l'arrivée
des tests rapides qui sont rendus
disponibles puis même on a commencé à
faire dans les lignes d'attentes donc
c'est de mon deuxième point ci à des
personnes symptomatique qui sont dans la
file d'attenté on leur donne un test
rapide est déjà là on peut leur dire
écoutez revenu un peu plus tard on sait
vous allez déjà vous avez vous avez des
symptômes allez vous isoler alors on est
en train d'ajuster ça mais c'est sûr
quand on est rendu à 3000 c'est ça et
peut-être plus dans les prochains jours
c'est sûr qu'une augmentation mais tout
me plie québécois comprennent une chose
c'est que on eu jusqu'à maintenant
garder un équilibre entre le personnel
qui était dans nos centres de
vaccination il faut vacciner ça c'est
notre priorité si ça retarde un peu dans
le dépistage mais je pense que
l'accommodement avec eux ce qu'on nomme
ce que je viens d'expliquer des tests
rapides et troisièmement je tenais là
dessus c'est je contribue tout à l'heure
j'ai dit au premier ministre 1500
personnes c'est des derniers chefs que
j'ai eues mais j'ai beaucoup de jacques
peuvent accompagner dans les files
d'attentes d'assaut c'est pô juste des
bâtis nateur alors on va redistribuer
dans les centres de dépistage déjà
qu'ils viennent nous aider à mieux gérer
des files d'attentes et en suivi pour ce
qu'est la capacité est ce que ça touche
aussi les chalets des centres de ski
si ça va toucher les centres il centre
des skis écoutez on vote on a toujours
eu le principe qu'on annonce aujourd'hui
ses ponts 10 et 50% par tous alors ne
pas fait de mesures particulières pour
les centres de ski étant une activité je
dirais extérieur mais dans le chalet
comme tel c'est audi seat comme un
restaurant alors faut avoir la même la
même exigence parce qu' on le répète
c'est une question de contacts si on est
capable d'avoir 50 % de moins de
contacts mais il ya une grande chance
qu'on va beaucoup moins que dans les
prochaines semaines c'est ce qu'il faut
faire merci va faire à nouveau sabrina
rive est de nouveau monsieur legault
l'an dernier à pareille date on est à
quelques semaines à peine d'instaurer un
couvre-feu en étant confinement est-ce
qu'on exclut présentement ces mesures-là
de confinement ou de couvre feu au cours
des prochaines semaines même si la
situation s'envenime
écoutez une différence une différence
énorme avec l'année dernière à la même
date sur la vaccination
par contre ça prenne troisième dos donc
l'eau on va accélérer la troisième dose
donc faute n'est content de ça mais
évidemment de stars voir à chaque jour
le pot l'instant les mesures qu'on
annonce on pense que c'est suffisant et
que ça va nous permettre de passer au
travers mais ce n'est pas impossible que
la semaine prochaine on sera obligés
d'ajuster c'est pas impossible mais avec
tes données qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est de
l'information qui est imparfaite c'est
ce sont les mesures qu'on pense qu'on a
besoin de mettre en place
une question que ledit côté via bonjour
à vous trois
c'est un point de presse qui a un petit
air de déjà vu
malheureusement est ce que dans les
mesures qui sont considérés contenant
conques du convoi les projections en ce
moment là qui augure rien de bon on est
dans les plans de délestage dans les
hôpitaux
jusqu'à maintenant non la bonne nouvelle
c'est que on est capable à ce format de
faire toutes les activités mais si
j'avais un cheval parce que c'est
peut-être un choix qu'on va avoir lieu
peut-être du délestage à certaines
activités là je parle pas d'urgence par
pau de chirurgie mais dans certaines
activités si je t'ai pas capables
d'augmenter la vaccination au niveau je
le veux la bonne nouvelle souvent la
bonne nouvelle fois trouvé des brunes
nouvelle mais c'est dès la réaction déjà
je contribue lé pourrait nous permettre
de limiter le délestage alors
laissez-nous quelques jours parce que
l'or on va faire demain après demain on
va regarder comment on peut passer du
cinquante mille à 75 milles par jour aux
passants 1000 par jour mais ça
j'aimerais soit capable de le faire sans
délestage de sion merci ma prochaine
question et pour d'autres arbres
la semaine dernière dans les derniers
jours qu'on a annoncé les rassemblements
de 20 personnes tout le monde a un ton
optimiste au lit on voyait bien là ce
qui s'en venait notamment en europe est
ce que vous vous êtes trompés
ce que j'ai dit c'est ta page sur le
triple des millions celles qu'on
observait chez nous j'ai dit qu'on
prenait un risque calculé j'ai mentionné
qu'on peut aller jusqu'à 20 mai
qu'idéalement fallait diminuer le nombre
c'est ce que j'ai fait mais là faut
comprendre que les choses sont
complètement évolué au micro c'est comme
un changement majeur on savait pas à ce
moment là jusqu'où ils allaient se
rendent chez nous je vais vous rappeler
que mardi dernier le 7 décembre ne
tester plusieurs de nos extension puis
avait aucun au micro actuellement on est
à peu près à 20% comme tel donc je pense
que c'est ce que je me suis trompé si
j'avais su aujourd'hui qu'on annonçait
ça peut-être que je leur ai dit je
l'aurais pas fait mais c'était un risque
calculé
acceptable chez vous dire que
comparativement que ça beaucoup d'autres
provinces qui ont maintenant encore
maintenus de 25 personnes et s'est monté
à 20 s'était jugé qu en mai experts
comme un potentiel et c'est dans ce sens
que je peux que je peux répondre mais
prime la pression actuellement elle
vient de l'épidémiologie dit au micro et
moi j'agis sur l'effet sur les éléments
on peut essayer de prévoir et les
projections hospitalière non plus
n'était pas du tout les mêmes que ce
qu'on a maintenant avec l'euro me trompe
ou voies rapides et de la tête monsieur
legault vous êtes d'accord avec mme
sarda il a encore votre confiance
écoutez la semaine passée on peut en eau
tous les lundis soirs une présentation
de l'inesss delienne spq et ça changeait
complètement cette semaine donc
évidemment partie du moment où les
prévisions change bien des mesures
annoncées change qui est comme je dis
tente où la foi et un but face à sedan
faut pas céder des parts accueil jeu je
veux garder l'opinion que j'avais une
semaine les chefs évolue tellement
rapidement qu'il faut s'ajuster
je voudrais juste mon premier point de
presse j'avais dit que ce que je disais
aujourd'hui elle est peut-être changé de
mains parce que je savais qu'on faisait
face à une bête qu'elle est nous amener
d'énormes surprises est ce que je
pourrais juste peut-être d'un côté
rajouter un point on a entendu beaucoup
des commentaires des québécois depuis
depuis une semaine sur le sujet puis je
pense qu'il est important de profiter de
ce soir donc pour dire oui à un party de
noël de 10 personnes c'est encore
possible mais pas cinq parties de dix
personnes
salaire peut-être un peu
[Musique]
inapproprié dire ça mais ce qu'on veut
puisque nos experts nous disent et fou
de limiter les contacts alors si on est
sur ma mensuel que vous voulez faire une
une soirée de noël dans une fois cinq
soirs et dix personnes
ce soit je pense qu'il faut retenir il
faut limiter le nombre de contacts
durant cette période là alors il ya
juste le préciser pour être sûr que tout
le monde le comprenne bien merci
prochaine question de l'art de radio
canada j'ai une question à propos de
l'efficacité des vaccins il ya deux
jours à peine on apprenait à ont dit
qu'il fallait apprendre à vivre avec le
virus et lost un peu la panique en le
micro la hausse des cas au québec alors
on se demande malgré tous les efforts
déployés est-ce que les vaccins sont
aussi efficace qu'on le croyait après
six mois est ce qui nous protège
vraiment du virus et si oui pourquoi on
rit instaure des mesures qui étaient en
place avant la vaccination des québécois
peut-être avant de dire les pourcentages
me reçoive continent noir pour faire
rapidement
jusqu'à lundi dernier avant d'avoir
justement des nouvelles sur au micro on
savait qu'elle même perte d'efficacité
par rapport au delta à peu près après
après six mois dans ce sens le programme
de vaccination troisième dose suivait
son cours comme tels parce qu'on était
dans le 75 80 % de protection puis en
bas de ça c'était approprié de faire une
troisième dose ça c'est à 20 ans
migrants arrivent aux migrants qui nous
disent maintenant vous avez encore une
protection avec vos anciens vaccin ça
c'est encore une bonne nouvelle sauf que
cette variation est réservé aux plaisirs
et l'aube et s'est énormément parce que
c'est pas le même vaccin pour le mend a
rien ici pour ce qu'il faut accélérer la
troisième dose on se comprend parce qu'
elle ne sera pas parfaitement la
protection mais c'est mieux de partir de
70% à 30 que comparer un non vaccinés
quitte à 0 alors je voulais juste vous
conter cette soirée c'est ça qui a
changé cette semaine de façon
excessivement je voulais juste donner
cette explication n'a peut-être
maintenant je voudrais peut-être par
quand même passer un message qui est
important la vaccination c'est notre
meilleure arme contre cette maladie
c'était important faut pas que les gens
disent que parce que on peut la traiter
l'infection plat transmettre que le
vaccin pas bon au contraire si
actuellement on n'avait pas le vaccin on
à rennes aux hôpitaux complètement
débordés et puis les gens et c'est aux
soins intensifs donc ça demeure encore
très important la première dose la
deuxième la troisième selon l'ordre de
priorité l'autre élément c'est pas parce
que vous arrivez à quatre mois trois
quarts que le ca tombe sa chute six mois
c'est quelque chose qui est acceptable
mais on dans le contexte actuel on peut
descendre l'hymne allemand trop en bois
je pense que j'entends que ça fait
quatre mois ou cinq mois
ça va être la catastrophe s'attend pas à
0 l'enjeu avec le au micro il est
tellement transmissibles tellement
tellement transmissibles qui va finir
par frapper du monde qui ont une moins
bonne immunité et par le fait que
beaucoup de corps on va avoir des côtés
mais c'est incomparablement pas pareil
que son aile mais pas le vexer la preuve
regardez là on n'avait pas le vaccin nos
gens dans les stages et celle des
axonais extrait en train de revivre ce
qu'on a vécu dans les intérieurs donc
faudrait pas que les gens pensent que
non ça m'a rien donné de faire de
l'accès oui ça vous a donné quelque
chose vous allez peut-être faire ma
maladie peut-être à transmettre à
quelqu'un mais vous serez probablement
beaucoup moins de chance d'être
hospitalisée donc moi je veux vraiment
pas que les gens retiennent que le
vaccin sans rien donner le vaccin c'est
la solution mais avec le verrions micron
puis avec le temps on se rend compte que
ça prendrait une 3ème de hausse
particulièrement pour les plus
vulnérables les plus à risques les plus
jeunes de 18 15 ans de façon très très
majoritaire rapport d exception se
retrouveront pour son état cefrio cité
des citrons la côte est de 19 ils vont
avoir bu de symptômes ou quelques
symptômes sa chaussette très très très
très important
faites vous vacciner et pour cible son
taux d'accidents le plus beau cadeau que
vous pouvez vous faire parce que là ça
se transmet beaucoup vous allez être
exposés probablement parce que beaucoup
beaucoup de cas c'est de vous faire
vacciner même pour la première dos pour
pas vous retrouver à l'hôpital puis
pourquoi votre trousse intensifs j'ai
peut-être une question un peu plus
spécifique toutes ces mesures là entre
en vigueur ou à peu près tout ce lundi
20 décembre il ya des grands événements
fin de semaine je pense au spectacle des
cowboys fringants qui va attirer package
au métropolis bon c'est le centre bell
ce soir c'est à huis clos le match des
canadiens mais reconnaît-il pour les
spectacles qui ont lieu partout au
québec en fin de semaine mais on a des
discussions à avoir par rapport à ça
j'aimerais pas vous donner une réponse
spécifique là alors qu'on n'a pas
débattu fait le répertoire de tout ce
qui va se passer c'est que c'est clair
qu'on agit rapidement aujourd'hui de
façon exceptionnelle pour la question du
centre bell mais tous comme tout ce qui
concerne les amphithéâtres une fille les
spectacles sont offerts une évaluation
de risques notamment avec les
organisateurs donc ça pourrait changer
pour le week end c'est ce que je
comprends c'est toujours possible comme
je vous le disais je sais pas je réponds
d'avancé sur des choses sur lesquelles
je peux fait l'évaluation mais ça
pourrait devenir question la presse
canadienne merci
oui bonjour à vous trois
monsieur dubé quand vous avez annoncé
les les rassemblements pour 20 personnes
vous aviez aussi dit à ce moment-là
qu'il n'était pas question de faire une
vérification policière de ce qui va se
passer tout ce
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que la
plupart des québécois ont probablement
fait des plans pour 20 qu'en est il
maintenant à 10 est ce que vous allez
davantage incité des corps policiers à
faire une surveillance dans les
résidences privées je vous pose la
question du tibet mais je la pose à vous
si monsieur legault ben je vais répondre
si la réponse est non on ne dit qu on se
fiait la responsabilité des des
québécois on y re profère d'inspection à
la maison je pense que c'est pour ça que
j'ai rappelé tout à l'heure que les
québécois ont très très bien et est
jusqu'à maintenant je vous donne un
exemple depuis qu'on a fait le point de
presse de mardi les québécois ont très
bien réagi en a quand même déjà décidé
de réduire leur activité
que ça soit des malheureusement des
super au restaurant p'tit
malheureusement parce que c'est
malheureux cuit mais c'est la bonne
décision à prendre alors on va encore se
fier à la responsabilité des québécois
et c'est pour ça que en or on ne dit que
c'était une question de contacts la
journée que les jeunes québécois savent
qu'il faut réduire le nombre de contacts
ça va se faire par lui-même par
responsabilité des surveillants ce qu'on
fait au niveau de la sûreté du québec
c'est pour appuyer
commerçants pour s'assurer qu'ils n'ont
pas de problèmes dans les exige le
passeport vaccinale que ce soit dans un
restaurant ou dans le bas et il va y
avoir au cours des prochaines semaines
une vigie dans les restaurants les bars
pour s'assurer que les gens respectent
d'exigence du passeport vaccinale
je peux ajouter la
spa une question de sa poignée ou
passera un panier quand on regarde le
nombre de corps on est passé de 1000 à
3000 700 par jour qui ont les experts
pensent ça va continuer d'augmenter
quand on regarde les hospitalisations en
très peu de temps on est passé de 200
hospitalisations à 300 hospitalisations
donc les québécois là ils doivent penser
à eux à leur santé à la santé de leurs
proches puis aussi au réseau de la santé
parce qu'on ne sait pas qui va avoir
besoin des services des hôpitaux dans
une semaine dans deux semaines le temps
que c'est pas une question est ce qu'on
va se faire à poigne et on sera pas
pogner ya un risque moi je demande aux
québécois la d'utiliser leur jugement il
ya une question de risque personnel une
question de risque pour leurs proches
puis une question de solidarité aussi
dans notre peuple est capable pas au
travail soigné tous les gens qui ont
besoin d'être soignés
en question est un petit peu plus
spécifique
étant donné que dans les salles de
spectacle reste ouverte et je pensé à
deux choses en même temps par exemple
dans les chu céder la plupart d'entre
eux ont des salles qui sont loués pour
recevoir de la famille pour des
occasions comme comme dans l la veille
de noël le jour de l'an vous êtes
certainement courant de terre ou de ce
probablement vous qui allez me répondre
là dessus mais en même temps il ya
beaucoup de spectacles de concerts qui
sont prévues où il ya des musiciens qui
sont plus que 10 qui doit faire des
répétitions
parce qu'on peut réduire dans la salle
mont réduira pas le nombre de docteurs
sur la scène pour une pièce de théâtre
ce genre de choses là quelles sont les
consignes qui sont prévus dans ces
cas-là spécifiquement pour les artistes
des arts de la culture et dans les ch et
ce dès les salles à louer dans les chu
soldées par des parts des familles je
vous remercie pour votre question parce
que pour 1 par rapport aux seychelles
des et les milieux comme les erp est
allé sur de consigne qui vont être
adressées l'on a réintroduit masques
dans les aires communes mais la gestion
par exemple d'installer à manger la
gestion des salles de réunion pics
savoie y avoir des guides spécifiques y
est il va y avoir certaines ajoutent
contraintes qui se permettre quand même
aux gens de pouvoir vivre mais pas les
exposer à un risque important que ça va
se faire notamment la gestion des salles
à dîner la capacité de la salle à dîner
il ya aussi toute une série d'éléments
en lien avec des tice qui vont être
ajoutés dans les chsld x donc ça va ça
va être géré pour ce qui est du milieu
de la culture chien vous dire que il ya
des protocoles qui sont en place on n'a
pas l'intention d'empêcher les
spectacles d'avoir lieu sur scène
d'ailleurs le milieu de la culture très
bien collaboré soit au théâtre soit au
niveau des chercheurs ou des orchestres
en maintenant le nombre de la
distanciation qui est fait des approches
particulières donc ça va continuer ce
qu'on veut essayer diminué dans le
contexte actuel c'est les contacts entre
les personnes il faut aussi voir par
contre que dans les salles de spectacles
des gens sont assez abstrait manga de
leur mère l'ombre essayé du mieux un peu
de distance et pour éviter les
encombrements
mais c'est quand même des milieux qui
sont relativement sécuritaire encore
avec d'avec ses consignes aux consignes
qu'on est chez nous mais qui existent
poinsot maillard s'achève en cela
il ya des gens qui vont se demander
pourquoi on n'applique pas les mêmes
règles dans une salle de spectacle un
restaurant ou dans une maison faut
comprendre qu'il ya des ducs sont
supervisés avec dépasse pas un contrôle
qui passe par vaccinale à l'entrée ce
qui n'est pas le cas dans les maisons
aussi donc faut aussi garder ça en tête
quand on compare un restaurant avec une
maison
prochaine question
bonjour messieurs pascal gâchettes du
journal métro on se retrouvait en
novembre 2020 avec un contrat moral qui
avait été proposé aux québécois qui
malheureusement a été brisée dû à la
colite forcément on se retrouve un an
plus tard avec une promesse est facile a
admis brisé je voulais savoir comment
vous sentiez comment vous viviez le fait
d'être celui qui apporte les mauvaises
nouvelles dans une période festive
écoutez moi je pourrais gagner un
concours de popularité je suis là pour
essayer d'assurer sécurité aux québécois
et
quand on demande aux québécois de faire
un effort ben c'est pas pour me faire
plaisir c'est pour être capable d'éviter
des conséquences graves pour les
individus qui éviter aussi l'engagement
de nos hôpitaux et on sait la situation
est fragile puis moi je demande qu'on
pense aux travailleurs de la santé et
donc je comprends que la situation
évolue quand vous regardez la carte de
l'évolution des codes loyer de lui
quatre vagues dont il ya eu des hauts
des bords et il faut s'ajuster
continuellement et
il y à il ya beaucoup d'inconnues il ya
beaucoup de désinformation qui est pas
parfaite mais moi ma responsabilité
comme premier ministre c'est d'agir dès
que j'ai l'information
si vous me permettez en tant que médecin
de santé publique moi mon rôle c'est
d'assurer de regarder l'épidémiologie
pour poser un diagnostic
c'est d'anticiper des choses mais je
peux pas non plus toujours savoir tout
comme le médecin doit avoir besoin de
certains examens pour confirmer si c'est
un cancer ou pas et notre rôle c'est de
jour faire l'amère décision à chaque
moment qu'on le fait pour le bien et
sauver des vies parce qu'ici notre
objectif c'est de sauver des vies puis
de maintenir un système de soins parce
que aussi d'autres maladies pour
lesquelles les gens ont besoin d'être
traités c'est que notre comme dit l'un
d'eux premier ministre notre orgueil ce
qu'on le dit art etc ça doit être motivé
c'est vraiment le portrait
épidémiologique est ce qu'on veut c'est
minimiser au maximum l'impact de sow
pour nos québécois
l'association sur la stratégie de
l'administration de la troisième dose
donc ce serait plutôt pour monsieur dubé
on a vu hier que le ministre fédéral de
la santé du klondike la troisième dose
était essentiel par la suite l'ontario a
lancé la campagne de vaccination pour
les 18 ans et plus dès lundi donc c'est
la troisième dose pour tout le monde dès
lundi qu'est ce qui empêche le québec de
faire la même chose et donc de la
proposer à tout le monde est ce que
c'est la juste la stratégie ou plutôt la
capacité de vaccination non ça n'a rien
à voir avec la capacité de vaccination
soyons très clairs jusqu'à hier jusqu'à
ce matin on avait une limitation de
d'être l'intervalle à six mois c'était
le principal facteur qui nous empêche
d'aller plus rapidement pour la
vaccination parce que jusqu'à maintenant
on avait les 70 ans et plus et même on
n'utilisait pas totalement notre
capacité donc ça c'est la première chose
alors dos qu'on eut la nouvelle la
nouvelle recommandation de la santé
publique on pouvait passer à trois mois
mais classé de conseillers et ajuster
maintenant pour l'ordre je pense qu'ils
tout à fait normal d'abord le même ordre
qu on a toujours suivi au cours des deux
dernières années on commence à avoir
l'expérience de commencer avec nos
clientèles vulnérables
puis comme le dit le premier ministre
leur pense pas qui est acceptable pour
quelqu'un de de 30 ans ou 40 ans de
passer devant quelqu'un qui venait rabou
un travailleur de la santé alors ce
qu'on fait avec les dates pour on a
cette expérience le maintenant et les
dates que j'ai donnée par exemple pour
les 60 ans et plus au cours des deux
prochaines semaines si on est capable
d'aller plus rapidement on va aller plus
être aux 60 ans et moins mais je pense
qu'il faut être réaliste de finir nos
travailleurs de la santé toutes nos
personnes vulnérables
les 60 ans et plus est de passer par la
suite rapidement mais je vous le dis on
va communiquer avec les autres avec les
autres personnes aussitôt qu'on a des
nouvelles dates je suis né je voudrais
ajouter un élément important je pense
qu'il est important de le dire on nous
compare beaucoup et c'est correct qu'on
puisse contenir une pose problème mais
au québec on a pris une décision de de
répartir la distance entre la première
le jem dojo début rappelez vous à 16
semaines les études ont très bien
démontré que les chèques insisté
vaccinale est meilleure avec des
intervalles plus long maintenant ses
douches contre qui recommandait et ça
change notre épidémie le jus par rapport
à d'autres provinces qui ont commencé la
troisième dose antérieurement parce
qu'ils avaient donné le vaccin à 28
jours à 21 jours ça je pense qu'il faut
pas l'oublier est pour ça qu on peut
comparer les pays à l'autre mais vous
regardez le contexte l'épidémie au et
des choix des programmes qui ont été
mises en place et ça c'est un des
facteurs qui fait que la question de
l'urgence donné la troisième dose
antérieurement avant le jeu vous dire
elle au micron tech sète hérault était
beau comme un rendez vous
une dernière question en français avant
de passer en anglais oui bonjour jean
louis le bourg de l'autre journal le
devoir je me demandais ce que vous aller
ajuster le passeport vaccinale a donné
que deux doses n'est plus la garantie
d'une protection adéquate ça va être en
discussions pour une évaluation comme
tel parce qu'il faut aussi s'assurer
qu'on ne brime pas l'accès à des choses
qu'on pense à moi ça va ça va ça va être
regardé effectivement ce sera pas demain
matin je sais pas mais matin ce qui est
important pour nous actuellement c'est
que les gens aient leur dos que nos
personnes âgées de 70 ans et plus une
ordonnance est aussi celle des noues 61
55 comment savoir leur dos et puis quand
on devrait être assez je voudrais
généralisée en termes d'éléments pourra
évaluer la situation ces deux là sont
explicites techniquement c'est très
facile moi sur mon téléphone aujourd'hui
j'ai ma troisième dose alors c'est très
facile de passer une fois qu'on leur
fait plus que vous recevez une mise à
jour lorsque vous avez la troisième tout
comme on l'a fait la dernière fois on
peut pas de négliger parce qu axa quand
des gens pour une opportunité d'avoir
été vacciné
avec une autre question pour vous
monsieur good on fait ce qu'on est sûr
que la hausse des cas va se traduire en
une hausse des hospitalisations pourquoi
on en est là bon la relative bonne
nouvelle encore excellement c'est qu'on
a observé une hausse importante avec une
augmentation légère déviation
ce qu'on appelle encore la dissociation
des commandes puis les hospitalisations
les autres vont pas aussi vite le
problème c'est que si les cas augmentent
trop bas ce moment là de par le fait de
la quantité il finit par avoir un impact
ces hausses pitt ce qu'on vise nous
c'est d'éviter que les communes trop
rapidement alors une période critique
aussi parce que le mois de janvier
février c'est le mois des infections
respiratoires c'est un mot qui toujours
plus difficile pour le réseau de la
santé donc c'est d'essayer de voir est
ce que ça monte poteau pour pour être
capable de garder notre système en
fonctionnement je ne crois pas que ça va
faire comme ça revenir comme ça mais ça
va être assez élevé selon les
projections pour nous préoccuper pour
protéger le système de soins mais aussi
au travers de la santé parce que les
autres super vite malade et on peut on a
besoin c'est pour ça que j'invite
véritablement aussi les travers de la
santé a et technique en a quelques-uns
qui peuvent se faire infecter dans leurs
enfants
l'explication que vient de donner
mesdames et messieurs le docteur arruda
résume bien tout c'est un point tout ce
point de presse l'écart augmente de
façon rapide au québec pour l'instant
les hospitalisations non d'augmenter au
même rythme et si a beaucoup beaucoup de
cas il y aura éventuellement sébastien
bovet trop de gens dans les hôpitaux
dont un autre maître de cheval - de
jean-noël dix personnes 50 % de moins de
contacts un peu partout sébastien alors
ce sac ça se décline dans les magasins
dans les salles de spectacles partout où
il ya des contacts possibles oui et la
phrase clé de ce point presse que le
message que le gouvernement veut envoyer
aux québécois c'est réduisez vos
contacts ça peut se résumer en une
phrase vous pouvez faire un parti à 10
personnes mais cinq partait à 10
personnes présentant des fêtes c'est
mieux de ne pas le faire c'est christian
dubé je pense qui a dit ça
donc l'idée c'est de réduire de la
moitié les contacts que les québécois
devaient avoir au cours des prochains
jours et des prochaines semaines et
s'ils ont réussi à réduire de moitié les
contacts qu'on devait avoir ont réussi à
freiner la progression du baril au micro
et la progression du nombre de cas au
québec dans les changements qui vont
toucher le 50% de moins de contacts dans
l'est gazin dans les salles de
spectacles cetera ça touche les gens
parlons des écoles avant de se quitter
c'est important pour les écoles
primaires il n'y a pas de changement on
redemande le masque partout à l'école
mais pour les élèves du secondaire
sébastien la rentrée est reporté au 10
janvier voilà décalée d'une semaine donc
la rentrée en présence dans les écoles
pour le secondaire en effet et le masque
re devient obligatoire partout dans les
écoles que ce soit en cash dans les
aires communes aussi à partir du 20
décembre s'ils ont compromis et 20
décembre c'est le dit très bien les
tout-petits demain qui doivent aller à
l'école devant l'école parce que la
campagne de vaccination se poursuit en
passant à l'école et la semaine
prochaine également jusqu'à mercredi
dans certaines
dans certaines écoles sébastien merci
beaucoup mais n'a pesé messieurs merci
beaucoup de votre attention sur rdi had
marie va poursuivre avec l'analyse tout
ça bien sûr et vous l'avez vu un
sentiment de retour en arrière
gigantesque mais c'est comme ça on se
retrouve nous demain je rencontre le 1er
mai justin trudeau demain on vous
présentera demain on va évidemment
parler de covè merci
c'était pas sur la liste de tam a
[Musique]
coché toutes les cases de votre liste de
noël ah oui seul endroit recherché
tanguay et sur tanguay point ca